Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan. Wir sitzen vor dem Salon und werden gleich in die Lektüre einsteigen. Aber zunächst muss ich dir eine traurige Geschichte erzählen. Ich war vor zwei Tagen in der Bank, denn du weißt, ich lege noch viel Wert auf Bargeld. War also dort und habe auch noch kein Personal mehr. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Viel trauriger. Es sind alte Leute. Natürlich sind alte Leute in der Bank gerade vormittags, aber ich erlebe dann dort ein sehr ungewöhnliches oder vielleicht ein sehr gewöhnliches Gespräch. Aber es ist so, dass ja doch, wenn man ein bisschen mehr in der Provinz ist, dort manchmal eine Rede laut wird, die eine solche Ehrlichkeit und Drastik hat, dass man ganz zerschüttert ist. Und so war es. Ich stand also da, holte Kontoauszüge, nahm Geld ab und dort unterhielten sich zwei Männer, so um die 80. Ja, mit der Gesundheit geht ja auch nicht mehr. So und die Frau ist krank und muss man mal sehen, wie das weitergeht. Wir sind ja nie viel in den Urlaub gefahren. Und so haben sie dann erzählt. Ja, man hat ja auch immer viel gearbeitet. Und dann haben die sich so ein bisschen hoch geschaukelt. Und irgendwann sagte der eine zu dem anderen, Peter, im Prinzip ist das Leben an uns vorbei gegangen. Und das war so dramatisch zu hören. Und danach ging das Gespräch aber dann noch so kurz weiter und dann verabschiedeten sie sich. Aber dass man so morgens unvermittelt in der Bank nur gerade Geld abhebt und dann einen Satz hört, Peter, im Prinzip ist das Leben an uns vorbei gegangen, ist etwas, woraus Thomas Bernhardt gleich einen Roman schreiben würde. Aber das ist ja etwas, was einen dann doch erschüttert, weil man natürlich sehr viel darüber nachdenkt, ob man auch beispielsweise mit 80 in der Bank steht, jemanden wieder trifft und sagt im Grunde ist das Leben an einem vorbei gegangen. Also es ist auch noch mal so ein Weckruf vielleicht zu sagen, was ist einem wichtig und wie lässt man das Leben nicht an sich vorübergehen.
Dazu habe ich einen kleinen Lebenstipp. Wir haben ihn häufiger, wir werden ihn noch häufiger haben. Aber Leute fragten in YouTube-Kommentaren, ob ich übergeschnappt sei, wegen eines Satzes im Podcast, den ich aber gleich wiederhole, was bedeutet. Nein, ich bin nicht übergeknabbt, ich meine ihn, wie ich ihn gesagt habe. Ich war seit wir letzten Freitag aufgenommen haben, zweimal in der Oper. In verschiedenen. Ich war das erste Mal außerhalb Frankfurts in einer Oper. Ich bin dafür sehr weit gefahren in eine Region Deutschlands, bei der man typischerweise vermuten würde, dass Menschen vor der Bank stehen, weil sie schon vor zehn Jahren geschlossen hat und sagen, Peter, ich glaube, das war nichts. So und ich möchte den Satz noch mal wiederholen. Und mir fiel es wieder auf, als ich in der Oper saß. Es ist wirklich gut, wenn alle einfach mal die Klappe halten. Wenn sich alle darauf einigen, da vorne spielt die Musik. Wir haben es hier mit Bühnenrealität zu tun. Es gibt gar nicht viel zu diskutieren. Man kann ein bisschen sagen, wie es einem gefallen hat und ob man das Gimmick erkannt hat oder wie auch immer. Danach. Ganz wichtig. Aber währenddessen ist einfach Mucks-Mäuschen still. Und das ist gut. Ich finde es gut, wenn alle mal die Klappe halten und sich darauf verständigen, dass das gerade der beste Zustand für alle ist, wenn jetzt einfach mal Ruhe ist. Denn ich habe natürlich auch nachgelesen, was zu Bad Oeynhausen von Politikern wieder gesagt wurde. Und es ist ja haarsträubend, wie schon die Anmerkungen von Felsa. Die sollen alle mal fünf Jahre ins Gefängnis für ein Lied vor Kamera. Alle mal die Klappe halten.
Ich würde sie auch in jedes Programmheft vor allem reinschreiben.
Gleich am Anfang. Lassen sie die Leute auf der Bühne spielen. Seien sie ruhig. Vielleicht genießen sie es.
Kannst du das in Frankfurt anbieten, dass du mal vor der Vorstellung kurz rauskommst und so eine kleine Ansprache hältst, dass jetzt Ruhe ist?
Leute, die zur Einführung des Stückes gehen wollen, gehen dahin, weil sie eine Ruhe haben will. Und man hat ja auch seine Ruhe. Also geht in die Oper das. Da herrscht Ruhe. Da ist Ruhe.
Dennoch sind ja Meinungsbekundungen nicht uns unangenehm. Es sind ja schon viele E-Mails eingegangen. Und zwar zu der Frage, sollten Kinder wählen dürfen? Sollten Eltern für ihre Kinder wählen dürfen? Da wir noch weiter E-Mails bekommen, heute Morgen haben wir auch schon wieder zwei bekommen, bevor ich losgefahren bin, sollten wir noch ein bisschen warten. Ich denke, in der nächsten regulären Folge werden wir dann über dieses Thema noch einmal sprechen. Ich werde mich auch munitionieren. Ohne Claude oder sonst irgendwen, sondern nur durch mich.
Als ob du diese Agenten nicht beim Namen nennst, obwohl du sie längst auf deinem Schreibtisch auch schon eingerichtet hast.
Perplexity ist sehr sinnvoll. Das nutze ich tatsächlich, weil das sehr schnell einen zu den Quellen aufführt. Aber das ist etwas, was wir noch später aufgreifen, worüber wir jetzt noch einmal ganz schnell reden sollten, ist, was ist da in den USA los?
Okay, ein Hinweis noch zu diesen Mails. Also das ausgeflagte Thema, was wir zufällig familien wollen, das behalten wir in der großen Folge, Monatsende. Wir werden aber wahrscheinlich noch mal, wenn wir uns ein Buch ausgewählt haben, ein Buch vorstellen. Alle weiteren Rückmeldungen, die wir bekommen haben, da klot, also wir lesen ja alle E-Mails und ihr kriegt ja auch viele Antworten von uns. Aber ich glaube, es lohnt sich jetzt, diese AI-Assistenz einfach zu nehmen, um dann in zehn Minuten mündlich im Vortrag mal alle Mails durchzugehen, was so der Tenor der Rückmeldung aus der Hörerschaft ist. Das machen wir dann, wenn wir so mitten im Monat irgendwann ein Buch ausgewählt haben. Euch kurz sagen, welches das ist und dann können wir da kurz auf diese Mails eingehen. In Amerika.
Ich bin übrigens ein bisschen verblüfft, dass die Mails so alle deiner Position zustimmen. Fast alle.
Die Leute denken mit?
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Aber gut.
Wir sind gespannt auf deine Munition dann. Gut, also wir lesen ja heute Bücher. Zum einen Nico Semsrott, Arne Semsrott. Also zwei fast gleich klingende Menschen, die aber nicht gleich sind, sondern sie haben nur die gleichen Eltern. Sie sind Brüder. Der eine ganz deprimiert aus dem europäischen Parlament. Und man fragt sich so, kann so ein wahnsinnig impressionistisches Buch mit einer Geschichte des persönlichen Scheiterns wirklich ein politisches Buch sein? Das andere Arne Semsrott, der uns auf die Machtergreifung der Rechten vorbereitet. Und wir fragen uns, ist es schon soweit, dass wir am Anfang des Buches einen Hinweis brauchen? Nicht alles in diesem Buch ist wahr, kann aber wahr werden. Es ist ein politisches Sachbuch.
So.
Und vielleicht passen diese beiden Lektüren ganz wunderbar in diesem Monat, denn wir haben ein Urteil des amerikanischen Supreme Courts bekommen, das in Deutschland von deutschen Journalisten ungefähr so aufgegriffen wurde. Und ich mit Absicht keine Clips jetzt, die heben wir uns ja alle auf, sondern man hört jetzt einfach meine Ausführungen und wie ich das so formuliere und fragte, kann das wirklich sein? Ist es schon so weit? Also in Amerika hat der Supreme Court entschieden, dass der amerikanische Präsident nun absolute Immunität hat für alle Taten während seiner Amtszeit. In Deutschland angekommen ist, nein, auch ein Präsident kann immer noch mal irgendwo Privatperson sein und diese Sachen sind dann nicht absolut immun, weshalb dann irgendwie die Tagesschau ausflagt, Teilerfolge vorm Supreme Court, Teilimmunität für amerikanischen Präsidenten oder so. Ich habe von diesem Urteil gehört und habe gedacht, das kann ja wohl nicht sein, bin sofort zu YouTube. Die amerikanischen Kommentatoren waren natürlich viel schneller, MSNBC, Fox News, CNN und so weiter. Und dort ist der T-Novi folgt. Journalisten sitzen vor der Kamera und sagen, Kennen Sie Game of Thrones? Dort gibt es einen König, der kann alles machen, er steht über dem Gesetz. Und er hat eine rechte Hand, The Hand of the King, die ihm noch mal sekundiert und so ein paar Intrigen vorbereitet. Und dieses Bild wurde als Illustration benutzt, um zu beschreiben, der amerikanische Präsident ist jetzt The King Above the Law. Und er hat an seiner Seite einen Supreme Court, der letztentscheidlich immer entscheidet, wann der Präsident im Dienst ist und wann nicht. Der also darüber richtet, dass man eine Amtshandlung, die ist so absolut immun, dass sie nicht mal beobachtet werden darf. Also man darf sie journalistisch noch beschreiben. Aber Sachen, die da geschehen, gehen nicht mal als Zeugenmaterial oder Beweise in irgendwelche Gerichtsverfahren ein. Andere Kommentatoren sagen, ich hab das Urteil gelesen und da steht drin, die amerikanischen obersten Richter haben Angst davor, dass die Präsidentschaft gelähmt wird durch einen Präsidenten, der immer Strafverfolgung fürchtet. Wir haben aber gar keine Geschichte der Strafverfolgung amerikanischer Präsidenten. Donald Trump ist der allererste, der überhaupt mal angeklagt wurde und noch nicht belangt ist in irgendwelchen Sachen. Wir haben aber eine Geschichte der unendlichen Freiheit der Handlungsmöglichkeiten der amerikanischen Präsidenten. Und dann wird wirklich gesagt, sie dürfen einen nuklearen Holocaust auf der anderen Seite der Welt auslösen. Sie dürfen eine Million Menschen im Irak töten lassen. Nichts davon ist irgendwie strafrechtlich relevant gewesen. Braucht der amerikanische Präsident wirklich noch mehr Schutz? Also aus dieser Unverständlichkeit raus. Meine eigene Lesart ist, ich hab das mit Thomas im Fernsehpodcast schon mal besprochen, die Engländer haben irgendwann ihren König vom Hof gejagt und eine parlamentarische Demokratie eingeführt. Und die Amerikaner haben irgendwann den englischen König vom Hof gejagt. Eine konstitutionelle Monarchie. Und da war immer die Frage, in England zum Beispiel, der Premierminister. Ist das nur ein gewählter König? Oder ist es tatsächlich eine demokratische Institution, die also über das Gewähltsein hinaus noch Restraints hat? Und jetzt sehen wir gerade in England, ja, die wählen da und dann wird das auch relativ zügig ausgetauscht. Also Kirsten Dahmer wird heute schon zum Premierminister. Dort hat man irgendwie einen Wandel geschafft. In Amerika war diese Frage aber noch offen. Hat Amerika durch den Unabhängigkeitskrieg einfach nur den englischen König vom Hof gejagt und damit aber nur den englischen König und damit einen amerikanischen König installiert? Oder haben sie eine konstitutionelle, wie auch immer, der Kongress darf relativ viel, sogar über das Kriegsrecht entscheiden. Und der Präsident ist eine von drei Gewalten. Und der amerikanische Supreme Court hat jetzt entschieden, nein, es ist ein amerikanischer König. Er steht über dem Recht, er genießt absolute Immunität. Und man hört dann so Podcasts wie We The People von so einem Constitution-Institut. Also diesen We The People Podcast kann man gerne mal folgen. Das ist wirklich hochinteressant. Da sitzen dann vier Juraprofessoren, die sich darüber verständigen, dass der amerikanische Präsident jetzt mit Mörder davon kommt. Also er kann morden lassen. Die große Frage war jetzt, darf der amerikanische Präsident seinen eigenen politischen Rivalen im Land töten lassen? Und die Antwort von diesen Professoren ist, ja, in dem Urteil steht nichts, was dagegen spricht. Es muss nur eine Amtshandlung sein. Also der amerikanische Präsident muss direkt mit seinem Militär, mit seinen weiteren Verfassungsorganen, mit dem Justizminister, was auch immer. Man muss sich halt auch offiziell beauftragen. In dem Moment, wo er nicht jemanden privat beauftragt, irgendeinen Handlanger oder so ein Taugenichts oder wie auch immer, wie man sich das so vorstellt, kann man jemandem das machen, sondern er einen Regierungsapparat bemüht. Ist alles immun und nichts darf jemals irgendwo als Beweis auftauchen.
Und damit sind wir in der frühen Neuzeit angekommen. Das ist nämlich ein Thema der Souveränität, das man beispielsweise in den Dramen von Pierre Corneille sehr gut nachlesen kann. Ich empfehle das Stück Sinner. Da gibt es den Satz, den ich in und wieder auch in der Filmanalyse zitiert habe, wenn es um so Roland Emmerich-Filme geht, um Filme, denen das Weiße Haus bedroht ist. Und zwar heißt es da, die Staatsverbrechen, die der Krone gelten, verzeiht der Himmel, wenn sie gelingen. Das heißt also auch, den Weg ins Amt kann man sich bahnen. Und wenn man dann im Amt ist, dann ist man, dadurch, dass man es geschafft hat, von Gott quasi da eingesetzt. Und dann stellt sich nicht mehr die Frage, ob man über Leichen gegangen ist. Und das gilt natürlich auch dann in dem Prinzip, dass man sagt, um Präsident zu bleiben, tu ich das. Und das ist ja eine lange Diskussion. Wie ist eigentlich dieses Präsidentenamt zu verstehen? Es gibt diese Idee der Machtfülle des Präsidenten. Und wie groß ist diese Machtfülle? Wir haben schon bei Richard Nixon die Argumentation gehabt, damals in diesem Interview mit David Frost, ich durfte das tun, weil ich der Präsident bin. Und das ist jetzt nochmal das quasi abgesegnet vom Supreme Court, was so erstaunlich ist. Aber eigentlich war es als Debatte immer da. Und damit sind wir eigentlich in so einer frühen Neuzeit Souveränitätsidee angekommen.
Wir haben diese ikonografischen Gemälde, die finden wir eigentlich immer nur noch in Kirchen und so. Der weltliche Herrscher steht so, nicht wirklich im Boden verankert, er schwebt in der Luft. Und eine Banderole trennt Kopf und Körper. Und diese Banderole zeigt, alles darüber ist schon Himmel. Also diese sakralherrschaftliche, du bist nicht von mir entsandt, du bist weltlich, aber du bist von mir quasi beauftragt, du erbst einen göttlichen Auftrag, die Gnade Gottes, das Gottesgnadentum und so weiter. Da sind wir jetzt wieder.
Und wir haben aber zugleich so eine verrückte Debatte um die Gesundheitszustände der beiden Kandidaten.
Der weltliche Körper unten, das zerbröckelt alles, aber man hat sie oben befreit von allen Ketten. Und weil du jetzt Watergate und so angesprochen hast, also diese amerikanischen Jura-Professoren, lesen das Urteil und sagen nicht nur, sind alle Anklagen gegen Donald Trump jetzt nicht dich, sondern auch Watergate hätte unter dieser Bedingung niemals prozessiert werden dürfen.
Und Oliver Stone hat ja den Film Nixon gemacht und hat es wie ein Shakespeare-Königs-Drama angelegt. Und das war genau der richtige Zugang. Und diese zwei Körper, die du ansprichst, das ist ja diese Idee des Historikers, oder was heißt Idee, das Konzept, das er ausgearbeitet hat in einem sehr umfangreichen Buch von Hans Kantorowitsch, die zwei Körper des Königs. Also es gibt den biologischen und den idealen Körper. Und eigentlich soll der Präsident als idealer Körper erscheinen. Und wenn er dann zurückgeworfen ist auf den biologischen Körper, dann beginnen diese ganzen Debatten. Und dann sehen wir seine Fehlerhaftigkeit und sehen dann, dass er eigentlich nur ein Mensch ist. Und genau das muss übertüncht werden. Funktioniert aber nicht, wenn der Körper aufgrund von Geprächtigkeit zum Beispiel nicht mehr so funktioniert.
Genau, wir sind wieder zurückgeworfen auf zum einen die Biologie. Und dann, das ist das letzte, was jetzt noch blieb, der Wählerwille. Also der amerikanische Supreme Court hat gesagt, wenn ihr den nächsten Präsidenten wählt, ist es ein König. Wir wissen nicht mal genau, ob er nicht dann doch Wege findet, zu sagen, ich ernen mich erstmal auf Lebenszeit. Das ist ja die Strongman-Prinzip, was Trump bei Xi zum Beispiel immer bewundert hat, dass er es einfach hingekriegt hat. Und das andere ist, dass wir ja dieses Project 25 haben von der Heritage Foundation, die also sagen, wir krempeln hier eh alles um. Was jetzt bedeutet, diese amerikanische Wahl entscheidet jetzt einfach über alles. Also der Supreme Court sagt von sich selber, das ist ein Urteil for the ages. Seit Gründung war diese Frage zu entscheiden, was ist der amerikanische Präsident. Sie haben ihn jetzt aus diesem Gewaltenteilungs-Vitocracy, alle stehen sich selber auf dem Weg, der Präsident findet da keine Mehrheit, der Kongress findet da kein Gehör usw. Haben sie ihn einfach enthoben, also er steht jetzt über diesen Sachen, über der Constitution, über den Verfassungsgefüge und above the law ganz allgemein. Also das wissen die Wähler jetzt im Vorfeld, sofern sie sich dafür informieren. Und sie wissen, was sie programmatisch bekommen von der Heritage Foundation. Das heißt, alles läuft jetzt auf diesen, ja im November muss der Wähler einfach entscheiden, was er will. Und wenn er sich für Donald Trump entscheidet, dann hat er sich eben dafür entschieden. Also für diese neuen Prinzipien. Und auch für die programmatisch, das was die Heritage Foundation da anführt. Und dann, keine Ahnung, also da fehlen mir wirklich die Fantasie dafür, was das bedeutet. Und ich finde es unglaublich, wie die deutschen Journalisten darüber nicht reden. Weil sie sich nicht vorstellen können, dass das die Tragweite ist. Aber es ist die Tragweite. Also es ist wirklich brenzlig. In der Ansicht haben wir heute zwei sehr politische Bücher, die sehr impressionistisch damit umgehen. Also mit so der allgemeinen Großwetterlage.
Die Debatten sind ja verrückt. Es war jetzt gerade in Essen der AfD-Parteitag. Und dort gab es Proteste davor. Und dann twittert Cem Özdemir, ob beim damals abgesagten Aschermittwoch der Grünen oder heute beim Parteitag der unsäglichen AfD. Friedlicher Protest, ja. Auch deftig, aber nötig und bedrohliche Szenen. Schaden unserer Demokratie. Der Zweck heiligt dem Rechtsstaat nicht die Mitte. Es gilt der gleiche Maßstab. Und das ist eine interessante Äußerung. Ich will mich jetzt gar nicht auf diese große Gewaltdebatte einlassen. Die Frage ist aber, ob man jetzt hier über vereinzelte Gewaltaktionen spricht oder ob man wirklich versucht, massiven Protest zu machen. In dem Sinne, dass man sagt, wir wollen eigentlich versuchen, dass die Delegierten nicht ins Gebäude kommen, um dort ihren Parteitagen abzuhalten. Und damals sah man bei den Grünen auch Protestler, die wollten, dass die Grünen nicht in der Lage sind, den Aschermittwoch abzuhalten. Wenn ich jetzt eine solche Interpretation nehme, wie Cem Özdemir, dann sage ich damit eigentlich, also er verurteilt ja hier nicht einfach nur eine massive Gewalt, sondern er sagt friedlicher Protest ja. Aber es geht jetzt schon darum, naja, aber das Demokratische soll weiter stattfinden. Also der grüne Aschermittwoch wie der Parteitag der AfD. Wenn ich das so sehe wie Cem Özdemir, dann frage ich mich aber, warum denn überhaupt so ein großes Gewesen um die AfD? Dann kann ich doch sagen, das ist ein Parlamentarismus. Die AfD ist innerhalb der ewigen Diskussion, die im Parlament so stattfindet, auch eine weitere, vielleicht ein bisschen laute, vielleicht ein bisschen drille Stimme. Aber um mehr geht es nicht. Geht es aber doch um mehr. Und es scheint ja so zu sein, sonst würde man ja nicht auch gerade von Seiten der Grünen immer vor der AfD warnen. Anders warnt man ja vor der FDP oder CDU. Oder man koaliert auch mit denen. Also gibt es doch einen fundamentalen Unterschied. Und ich glaube, diesen fundamentalen Unterschied, den arbeitet Arne Semshorth in seinem Buch Machtübernahme hervorragend heraus. Und da muss man nämlich dann nochmal auch den Journalismus und auch diese ganzen Politiker, die sich jetzt äußern, sich zu Brust nehmen und sagen, also wenn ihr keine kategoriale Unterscheidung macht, sondern einfach nur sagt, der Grüne Aschermittwoch muss genauso stattfinden, wie AfD-Veranstaltungen stattfinden müssen, dann kann man sagen, dann ist es aber auch egal, ob Grün oder AfD. Wenn ihr sagt, es gibt aber doch einen fundamentalen Unterschied, und das heißt ja nicht, dass man jetzt auf Leute mit Axt und Beil losgeht, sondern wenn man sagt, es gibt einen fundamentalen Unterschied, dann müsste es auch einen fundamentalen Unterschied geben, bei der Form, wie man Protest einschätzt, ob er da oder dort stattfindet. Und ich glaube, dass Arne Semsort das sehr klar macht. Man versucht jetzt gerade von vielen Journalisten und Politikern aus, so eine unschuldige Neutralität herzustellen. Ich warne davor, zu sagen, dass man es mit der AfD genauso handhaben kann wie mit den anderen Parteien. Wenn dem so wäre, dann ist es einfach eine Partei, dann haben wir halt noch eine weitere Stimme. Die Marke ist einem nicht gefallen, aber dann ist doch eigentlich alles in Ordnung. Semsort zeigt, das ist jetzt nicht nur noch einfach eine andere Stimme, die da mit reinkommt.
Also ich glaube auch, die demokratischen Prinzipien sind sehr viel bedrohter, nicht nur in Amerika, als man so glaubt. Der Verweis auf, aber bitte keine Gewalt, ist natürlich voll richtig. Dem schließen wir uns ja auch an. Nur, man muss sich ja dann mal abseits dieser Themen die Frage stellen, in Deutschland besteht die Möglichkeit für Parteien, verfassungsgebende Mehrheiten zu erringen. Zum Beispiel die CSU in Bayern hatte unter Söder teilweise über 66% der Stimmen. Was würde die AfD damit machen? Und wenn man der Meinung ist, die AfD würde nicht aus so einer Legislaturperiode rausgehen und sich einfach abwählen lassen. Und ich bin ein Anhänger von so einer Vorstellung. Das sollte man in seinen Gefahren Haushalt mit einbauen, dass diese Gefahr besteht. So wie auch bei Trump. Wenn Trump gewählt wird, bin ich mir nicht so sicher, dass er nach vier Jahren einfach eine Wahl veranstaltet.
Da kann man sich bei der CDU sicher sein. Wir haben schon viel Schlimmes über die CDU gesagt, aber so schlimm sind sie nicht.
Genau, aber das ist bei AfD und den neuen Republikanern ganz anders. Und dann kann man das nicht einfach reduzieren auf, aber jetzt bitte keine Gewalt auf der Straße, sondern diese Gewalt auf der Straße antizipiert ja auch schon ein anderes Denken und Fühlen über die demokratischen Grundlagen dieser Gesellschaft. Und das muss man dann ernst nehmen. Und man kann diese Gewalt trotzdem ablehnen, sollte das auch, aber man kann es nicht dabei belassen, wie Cem Özdemir mit so einem Spruch.
Ja, denn dann ist es doch nicht dasselbe. Und ich würde auch sagen, man muss ein bisschen aufpassen, wenn man jetzt so tut, wie können wir jetzt wieder alle in ein Boot bringen? Die Gesellschaft war nie ein Boot. Und es gab dieses Berlin-Summit, wir haben ja über diese Verordnung oder was, ne, was ist das, so ein Aufruf, Weckruf, irgendwas? Eine Declaration haben wir ja schon gesprochen im letzten Salon. Du hast uns das ja wunderbar mit Claude gezeigt, wie man das eigentlich machen müsste. Aber es gab natürlich auch bei dieser Veranstaltung gute Vorträge, unter anderem von Adam Tooze. Und der setzt sich, ich empfehle diesen Vortrag, sich bei YouTube anzuhören, damit auseinander. Was sollen das eigentlich heißen? How can we win the people back? Ja, waren die je bei uns, die Leute? Und wen meinen wir da eigentlich? Und muss man alle mitnehmen der Gesellschaft für die grüne Transformation? Oder ich will hier, also ich meine nicht die Partei Grüne, sondern die ökologische Transformation. Und wir hören uns jetzt ein paar wenige Clips von Adam Toos an und wollen das als Vorbereitung nehmen für die beiden Bücher, über die wir sprechen, dass wir auch mal versuchen, diese Naivität abzulegen. Wir hören mal rein.
Wir brauchen nur eine solide Mehrheit. Das ist das, was Demokratie angeht. Das ist nicht die Menschen zu gewinnen, das ist Romantik. Was wir brauchen, ist eine Koalition, die wirklich funktioniert. In Deutschland ist das eine sehr starke und bedrohende Kontrolle. Eine Koalition, die wirklich funktioniert.
So, wir brauchen also nicht alle Menschen mitnehmen, sondern man muss sehen, dass man eine Macht erlangt und dann regiert man darüber, über die anderen. Es geht nicht darum, dass man sagt, jetzt müssen wir uns aber auch noch um die AfD-Wähler sorgen, dass deren Stimme auch weiterhin überall vorkommt.
Ja, diese Losung hatten wir von Gilda Sahibi. Man muss sich um die Anliegen aller Menschen kümmern, denn auch Neonazis haben durchaus ein paar lebenswerdliche Anliegen, die mit der Mehrheit konfront gehen. So unterschiedlich sind wir ja alle nicht. Man muss nur die rassistischen Belange ausflacken und dann einfach ignorieren. Dafür müssen die ihre eigene Mehrheit sorgen. Wenn sie Menschen im Mittelmeer töten wollen, dafür brauchen sie eine eigene Mehrheit. Mit, wenn man sie durchs Rentenalter bringt, ja, das kann man dann auch für die einfach machen. Da könnte sie sich durchaus in die Mehrheit einfach mal... Aber es muss halt klar markiert werden, ne, das ist ein rassistisches Belang. Darum kümmern wir uns jetzt hier nicht. Als SPD-geführtes Innenministerium. Und was macht Feser? Sie macht es doch die ganze Zeit.
Und wenn wir wieder zurückkommen zu Gramsci, was wir wirklich lieben würden, und ich bin ein Kind von Thatcherismus, was wir wirklich lieben würden, ist ein hegemonisches Block. Was wir wirklich lieben würden, ist eine wunderschöne Koalition, die nicht alle in eine andere Richtung bringt. Woher kommt diese dumme Phrase? Bringt alle in eine andere Richtung, keine anderen hinter sich. Wann war das letzte Mal, dass historische Veränderungen in diesem Thema passiert waren?
Also massive Bilder, Bulldozer, ja, also noch mal drüber nachdenken, auch bei all diesen Protesten und Aktionen und geht bitte zu Europa Wellen. Vielleicht da mal an den Bulldozer hin und wieder denken und nicht so Ringelreihe machen. Und ich spiele die Clips deshalb, weil ich ein bisschen diese Naivität merkwürdig finde, die Nico Semsrott an den Tag legt und bin so gleich verpluft darüber, wie Arne Semsrott es schafft, mit diesem Buch ganz klar herauszuarbeiten, wo die Macht liegt, wie man damit umzugehen hat und auch keine Angst davor hat, die ganze Zeit über Macht zu sprechen und wie man eine Hegemonie erlangt gegen rechts. Darum geht es. Also ich dachte erst, als du das Buch vorgeschlagen hattest, naja, ist das am Ende wieder so ein Buch, wir müssen uns mal alle unterhaken? Nein, es ist ein Buch, das in schönster Klarheit herausarbeitet, worum es eigentlich geht. Wir hören noch mal Tuus.
Und wenn wir sagen, dass wir einen Paradigm haben, dann müssen wir für den Gott sei Dank stehen und glauben. Wir müssen die Kraft unserer eigenen Verwaltungen haben. Was wir bauen müssen ist unser eigener Bulldozer, unsere eigene Maschine. Was wir brauchen ist unsere eigene Version von Tina. Das muss es sein. Das muss die Logik unseres Moves sein.
Um nicht nochmal erklären und ja, wir haben auch Verständnis dafür, dass wir doch da eine Finanzierungslücke haben und dass wir dies und das, dass wir es versuchen, auch mal jenem Recht zu machen. Das ist ja etwas, was man so ganz stark jetzt auch merkt bei Habeck, dass er versucht auch noch, das der CDU und der FDP und weiß ich nicht, wem alles schmackhaft zu machen, statt einfach selbstbewusst zu sagen, ja, diese Art der ökologischen Transformation bringt der Wirtschaft enorm viel. Das wird das neue Wachstumsmodell. Punkt.
Also wir hatten ja mal so ein sozialdemokratisches Jahrzehnt, von dem wir, haben wir ja bei Josef Hader gehört, sagen, ne, das war es nicht. Jetzt ist ja England wirklich abgeschmiert. Alle wissen Subkotan, das war der Brexit. Alles andere war da nur Garnitur obendrauf, also Pandemie und Krieg. Und Keir Starmer regiert jetzt mit 410 Leuten oder so im Unterhaus. Die haben die Tory-Fraktionen von, keine Ahnung, irgendwie 360 Leute jetzt auf 130 zurückgesprßt. Das ist ja jetzt eigentlich, also der Bulldozer ist jetzt eigentlich einmal in dieses Parlament gefahren. Und man kann nur hoffen, dass sie zur Besinnung kommen. Weil im Wahlkampf war das ja immer noch Thomas Bildt so. Da wird jetzt die Ming-Vase ganz vorsichtig durch diese Tory-verseuchte Landschaft getragen. Jetzt niemanden abspenstig verschrecken und so weiter. Aber jetzt ist der Bulldozer angekommen. Und eigentlich kann man jetzt mal ordentlich zu lang in England und die ein oder anderen Maßnahmen da ergreifen. Mal gucken, wie vorbildhaft es wird.
Aber kannst du dir vorstellen, dass Keir Starmer der Mann ist? Der wird hier übrigens auch sehr von Olaf Scholz gelobt. Und dann kann man vielleicht schon denken, ja, es ist ein weiterer Technokrat.
Mal sehen, mal sehen. Ich wollte nur anmerken, es geht. Der Bulldozer wäre da. Man kann einen Bulldozer mal losfahren lassen.
30% von Deutschen, die wenn eine Heizpumpe verschenkt, sie noch nicht nehmen würden. Wir geben sie ihnen zuerst, dann lassen wir alle anderen schauen. Die 70% die die Freie Heizpumpe wollen, gehen wir mit ihnen in jeder Gemeinschaft, wo sie ja sagen, dass sie uns eine Heizpumpe geben und dann drücken wir.
Ja, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, wie Olaf Scholz bei der IAA Mobility in München auf der Bühne steht und sagt, so im Zweidrittel seiner Rede, es ist ja ganz erstaunlich, dass man mit einem E-Auto, mit einer Tankfüllung, also das was sie heute kostet, drei bis fünf mal so weit fahren kann. Das sind ja solche Sachen, wo ich mich frage, warum ist das nicht Bulldozer, mit dem man da rein fährt in diese Messe? Warum wird das so versteckt irgendwo hinten, dass eine Wärmepumpe nur noch so und so wenig Prozente des bisherigen Energiebedarfs braucht und im Sommer noch kühlt? Die Leute sollten mit Handkuss zu ihrem Heizungstypen gehen und sagen, zum Glück ist gerade die Lebenszeit meiner vorherigen Heizung abgelaufen, ich kann mir jetzt endlich eine Wärmepumpe holen.
Aber Tuos geht ja so weit, man sollte eigentlich von der Regierung aus die Wärmepumpen verschenken. Also er will tatsächlich eine ganz, ganz große industriepolitische Maßnahme haben, damit gar nicht mehr die Diskussionen aufkommen. Denn wenn man es sich dann durchrechnet für viele Leute, gerade wenn sie älter sind, lohnt sich dann die Wärmepumpe in ein altes Haus zu installieren. Nicht, das ist zu teuer. Also machen sie es nicht. Wenn man natürlich sagt, ich will die Grüne Transformation und möchte, dass möglichst schnell alle anderen Heizungsmodelle abgeschafft werden, dann muss ich was in die Hand nehmen und muss das anbieten. Und genau das, was ja angeboten wurde von der Ampel als Ausgleich für arme Leute, ist ja etwas, wo man sagen muss, ja, das trifft ja nur eine Einkommensklasse, die sowieso keine Eigenheimen hat, also über diese Wärmepumpe gar nicht befinden kann. Die Leute, die so in so mittleren Einkommen sind, aber für die, das schon einen Unterschied macht, ob man 10.000 oder 20.000 Euro ausgibt, für die gibt es ja gar keine Förderung. Nun, wir wissen Haushaltsstreit und so weiter, aber ich würde auch noch mal deutlich machen, dass hätte man dann auch von vornherein wissen können, dass das so läuft. Also Stieglitz und Thuis haben es ja aufgeschrieben mit Lindner und man hat sich an diese Koalition begeben. Und das ist sehr gut, dass er sagt, ja, das ist zwar hybris, aber eigentlich ist genauso Politik. Also wenn diese Ulf Poschats immer so tun, als gäbe es eine neutrale Freiheit und dann kommen die Grünen oder die Sozialdemokraten und wollen dies oder das, dann muss man sagen, nein, die Konservativen, die CDU hat sich die Menschen gemacht, hat sich ihre Wähler gebastelt und hat die Menschen so verformt, dass sie irgendwann denken, also Erbschaftsteuer, das geht aber wirklich nicht. Diese Leute muss man erst mal kreieren, die sind nicht einfach so da, die kann man nicht pflücken, die kommen nicht von den Bäumen. Das ist eine konservative, große, metapolitische Leistung, die da vollbracht wird. Wenn man also von der anderen Seite kommt, dann muss man sich auch die Leute kreieren.
Ja, das kann man ja noch mal ein bisschen raffinieren, dieses Bild, denn die Leute sind ja keine Verfügungsmasse, die man sich dann hinbiegt und so, aber das Interessante...
Es ist ein sehr elitäres Sprechen, das Adam Tuss hier pflegt.
Genau, aber es ist ja nicht falsch.
Nein, nein.
Man muss es nur, finde ich, noch mal sozio-logisch reformulieren. Die Politik braucht nur Wähler. Was diese Wähler als Konsumenten, Eltern, Arbeitnehmer und darüber hinaus noch sind, alles egal. Man braucht nur diesen ganz kleinen Aspekt der Rolle Wähler. Und diese Wähler bekommen eben nicht das große freie Mega-Angebot, sondern in Amerika nur hü oder hot. Der 78-jährige irre König, der dann die ganze Welt in Brand steckt, oder halt der 82-jährige Präsident, der die Gouverneure einlädt, um ihnen zu sagen, sorry, aber Donald Trump hatte recht, ich bin Sleepy Joe, ich mach keine Termine nach 8 Uhr mehr, ich werde mir jetzt mehr ausschlafen und dann schaffen wir das schon mit der Wahl. Und egal, wie raffiniert, kompliziert und jeder von sich glaubt, ich bin ein super intelligenter Mensch, das ist die Alternative zwischen diesen beiden Leuten. Also selber kann man sich die Politik dann nicht aussuchen. Und die Politik hat einen leichten Zugriff auf diese ganz kleinen Aspekte, dass jeder einfach dann da sitzt und sich denkt, und da muss man sich jetzt 70 Millionen verschiedene Leute mit 70 Millionen verschiedenen Alltagen vorstellen, die am Ende doch alle entweder Biden oder Trump wählen. Also so in dieser Größenordnung teilen die sich unter sich auf. So und da kann man erst mal alles ausblenden. Also diese Verständnis-Pornografie, dann erst mal in den Osten zu fahren, sich Matze-Hilscher-mäßig mit jedem und deren Kindheit zu befassen, um am Ende ein Programm gegen die AfD zu entwickeln. Na gut, das ist alles gar nicht nötig. Die AfD macht das auch nicht. Die AfD geht einfach auf die leichtesten Instinkte und aktiviert einfach die politische Rolle. Und dann sagen die, ich will ein Strongman und das war's. Und der Rest der Personen wird ausgeblendet, völlig zurecht.
Nur hat die AfD sich auch Leute geformt. Also die sind nicht einfach so da. Die sind ja nicht einfach in der Gesellschaft.
Man hat sich diese Rolle, dass diese Menschen dann einfach sagen, ich will jetzt AfD, no matter what, mich interessiert der ganze Kram nicht. Ich hab mit meinem Alltag zu tun. Der AfD ist zum Glück egal, was ich den ganzen Tag mache. Die belehrt mich nicht, die bequatscht mich nicht, die kommt hier nicht um die Ecke und macht hier irgendwie. Und vor allem keine Vorwürfe aus Berlin. Ja, wenn die nächste große Sonntagsrede von Frank Walter kommt und so, die dann immer auf die Leute einwirken soll. Nein, die AfD ignoriert das einfach alles und sagt, Deutschland aber normal, sei wie du willst. Wir sind deine Ansprechpartner in der Politik. Beim Rest lassen wir dich in Ruhe. Und genau deswegen funktioniert das. Und so funktioniert die ganze Marktwirtschaft. Also jedes Produkt, und im Supermarkt ist es ja sehr viel komplizierter, da stehen 80 verschiedene Joghurt. In der Politik ist es eigentlich so einfach. Das sind fünf oder sechs Parteien, auf die es ankommt. Also man muss das aber gar nicht so kompliziert machen.
Nur was ich, glaube ich, unterstreichen würde, ist, dass die Parteien durchaus in der Lage sind, und gerade die Amerikanischen zeigen es ja, die beiden, dass man Menschen formen kann. Also Ronald Reagan ist nicht einfach gekommen, hat gesagt, hier ist mein neoliberales Programm, sondern man hat neoliberale Subjekte geformt. Durch Film, durch eine bestimmte Art des Sprechens, durch einen gewissen Lifestyle. Nicht im Sinne von, das hat Ronald Reagan alles alleine in Auftrag gegeben, aber dass plötzlich Leute sich mit Börsianern identifizieren, plötzlich glauben, auch sie können erfolgreiche Banker sein, obwohl sie zum Mindestlohn arbeiten, das sind ja Subjektbildungen, die entstanden sind, genauso wie auch bei Margaret Thatcher, die dafür gewirkt haben, dass wir bis heute eigentlich diese Ideologien in den Köpfen haben und dass man nur ein paar Dinge aufrufen muss und schon haben diese Parteien wieder Anklang, haben sie wieder Erfolg. Und ich glaube, das Projekt ökologische Transformation oder auch offene Grenzen oder ein Kampf gegen die Vermieter, das ist etwas, was nicht selbstbewusst vorgetragen wird, weil man gar nicht das Mietersubjekt je kreiert hat, sondern man hat immer von konservativer Seite so getan. Also, es ist in allen in einem Boot und Eigentum sehr wichtig.
Ja, also ich würde aus den Literaturen und Lehren, die wir hatten mit Claude und so weiter, sagen der sozialdemokratische Bulldozer. Wenn er nochmal, also wenn die Sozialdemokratie nochmal Erfolg haben will und das Bulldozer-Modell annimmt, sollten sie einfach das Programm fahren. Liebe Wähler, wir lassen dich in Ruhe. Unser einziges Angebot, wenn du uns wählst, fallen deine Wohnkosten um die Hälfte. Wie die das dann machen, das ist politische, professionelle Arbeit. Damit muss man den Wählern nicht belästigen. Also, es ist genug Geld da. Die Tagesthemen können ja dann darüber aufklären. 20 Billionen Privatvermögen in Deutschland, um die Hälfte zu senken, reichen 500 Milliarden davon. Da denkt man sich, das ist ja wohl zu machen. So wie die FDP ja auch kommt und sagt, eine Billion Steuereinnahmen, also das muss reichen. Punkt. Da wird ja auch keine Diskussion groß geführt. So, also diesen Bulldozer kann man doch einfach losfahren lassen. Und mit der Ansprache, liebe Wähler, wir senken eure Wohnkosten. Ja, nicht jeder ist davon betroffen. Also im Thüringer Land leben die Leute in Eigenheimen, denen kann es da irgendwie egal sein. Aber in den urbanen Zentren und da, wo sozusagen junge Leute dann auch mal losgehen und sagen, oh, das ist eine Idee, der euch folge. In Berlin sind 80 Prozent Mieter. Warum wird die von der CDU regiert, die da noch die Leute alle rechts und links vorher aus den anderen Regierungen rausschmeißt, die sich mal als Staatssekretär oder wie auch immer aus der Deckung wagen, um da was beim Thema Wohnpreise zu machen. Das ist doch völlig unverständlich. 80 Prozent, also wenn das keine mobilisierbare Mehrheit ist. Und in Berlin ist nochmal das Wohnen für alle Menschen das zentrale Thema. Das kann man sagen. Denen ist da eher offene Grenzen in Griechenland, keine Ahnung. Irgendwas mit, da ist nur eine Benzin-Lieferer, der hat irgendwas mit Russland, auch egal. Das ist alles egal. Also die Leute geben die Hälfte ihres Geldes für das Wohnen aus. Also ist das die Einflugschneise? Wo ist der Bulldozer, der da drin? Das versteht man doch nicht.
Ja, eine Moderatorin fragt nach dem Vortrag noch ganz kurz nach.
Ja, die Leute wissen nicht selber, was gut für sie ist.
Mit diesem Selbstbewusstsein muss man auftreten, sonst braucht man keine Politik machen.
Ja, jedes Unternehmen sagt, sorry Leute, aber auf Nachfrage können wir nicht warten. Wir machen es angebotsorientiert. Wir schmeißen hier mal was auf den Markt. Wenn die Leute das nicht wollen, dann hauen wir den Marketing hinterher, dass sie alle glauben, das deutsche Schicksal hängt davon ab, ob man im Adidas-Trikot ein Tor schießt oder nicht. Das ist eine völlig irre Idee, aber der folgen gerade alle in Deutschland.
Ja, das ist ja genau das, wenn irgendeine Politikerin, ein Politiker, da sitzt und sie sagen, ja, ich glaube, wir müssen mal einen Bürgerrat gründen, dann ist das für mich ein ganz deutliches Zeichen von absoluter Inkompetenz. Bei Apple geht niemand hin und sagt, ja, wir müssen jetzt mal so 500 Apple-User zusammensetzen, damit wir über die rausfinden, was wir als nächstes entwickeln können. Nein, Apple weiß es besser.
Apple hält alles geheim und sagt, das ist das neue Produkt. Ab morgen kannst du es vorbestellen, nächste Woche wird es geliefert. Und die Leute rennen dem Laden die Bude ein. Also es ist wirklich... Man kann Politik sehr viel besser machen. Wir bekommen heute ein Buch, das uns erklärt, wie, und ein Buch, das uns mit versucht, in die Depression zu ziehen. Und wir wehren uns natürlich dagegen, weil so kann man echt nicht über Politik. Also es tut mir alles sehr leid für Nico Semsrath, aber so geht es dann auch irgendwie nicht.
Nee, so geht es nicht. Aber ich würde schon sagen, es ist auch... Na ja, ich will nicht sagen...
Ein sehr wichtiges Artefakt.
Ja, ich will nicht sagen, es ist ein Generationen-Buch. Aber ich glaube, das Buch ist auch deshalb so erfolgreich. Nicht nur wegen ihm, sondern es ist auch deshalb erfolgreich, weil es eine allgemeine Grundstimmung bei Menschen unter 30, unter 40 abruft. Und das ist etwas, wo man ein bisschen gegen ankämpfen muss. Und das müssen wir heute tun.
Was sein Bruder ja macht.
Genau.
Es ist erstaunlich, dass sie sich kaum erwähnen. Eigentlich gar nicht. Nico erwähnt kurz Arne, aber ich glaube nicht, dass Arne irgendwo Nico erwähnt hat, oder?
Ich kann mich auch nicht dran erinnern. Also das Buch Machtübernahme jedenfalls ist hervorragend. Brüssel sehen und sterben. Darüber müssen wir diskutieren. Ich habe, wie angekündigt noch, das Buch abseits des Krieges dabei, des Philosophen Gunnar Hindrichs, der da sehr, sehr kluge Gedanken äußert über Militarismus, die Ideologie des Militarismus, das Heroische. Dann dachte ich mir, lesen wir doch mal chinesische Science-Fiction. Wir lesen eine Geschichte einer chinesischen Autorin. Also ich stelle diese Geschichte vor.
Giest mit dem Trend. Netflix hat es ja auch schon für sich erkannt.
Ja, ja, natürlich. Dann habe ich etwas ganz Wunderbares gelesen. Ich liebe ja Streichquartette und eine Konzert-Agentin, die die bedeutendsten Streichquartette der Welt betreut, hat ein Buch über Streichquartett geschrieben. Außerdem geht es noch um Landwirtschaft in der Ukraine und die Investoren bzw. Gläubiger, die unruhig werden. Ein Artikel von Simon Zeise. Und ich werde noch auf einen neuen Dating-Trend hinweisen. Ich sage aber gleich, für mich wäre es nichts.
Na dann für mich vielleicht. Klaus Badenhagen lebt in Taiwan, liebt seine Heimat und hat ein Buch noch mal darüber geschrieben. Oder was heißt noch mal? Er hat jetzt ein Buch darüber geschrieben, weil es keins gab in diesem Sinne, wie wir das alles verstehen müssen, was da passiert. Denn dass Taiwan so wichtig ist mit den Chips und dass Taiwan demokratisch ist, ist eine gerade mal 30-jährige Geschichte, die aber jetzt unbedingt zu schützen ist. Gerade in dieser Großwetterlage. Da schauen wir kurz rein. Außerdem, Christian Drosten hat ein Buch mit verfasst. Er hat es als Gespräch angelegt oder es wurde als Gespräch angelegt mit Georg Maskolo. Die beiden reden über Corona. Und in dem Fall würde ich sagen, das lohnt sich auch wirklich. Ihr kennt die Hörbuchversion nicht. Sie wird nicht von denen selber sein, weil es ist ja ein, sagen sie auch, editiertes, redigiertes Gespräch. Aber ich glaube, es lohnt sich für alle, den Sing-Sang solcher Aufarbeitung jetzt noch mal zu folgen. Also so eine Mischung aus spontaner Wortwechsel, aber trotzdem vorbereitet. Also er zitiert noch mal die entsprechenden Mails und so weiter. Und Christian Drosten hat Anliegen zum Thema Schulschließung, Pandemie allgemein und auch unsere Frage, das Publikum und die Politik. Eine Sache will ich nur jetzt schon erwähnen. Christian Drosten hatte am Anfang wirklich diese Idee, Politik, wozu brauche ich hier Politik? Ich muss doch nur die Öffentlichkeit darüber informieren und dann machen die das schon. Weil jeder möchte ja sein Leben retten, oder? Und diese Enttäuschung darüber, dass das nicht funktionierte. Und er sich plötzlich wiederfand in politischen Kreisen, weil er wusste, ich schaffe es, eine Überbande zu spielen. Ich muss die Politik informieren, damit die normativ bindenden Gesetze, in Anführungszeichen, aus Gremien, die es vorher so gar nicht gab. Also diese Enttäuschung nachzuvollziehen, war sehr augenöffnend, fand ich. Und er fühlte sich nicht wohl in der Politik und lobte immer wieder die Briten, wie die das gemacht haben, weil die für diese Art von Expertise eben Räume politisch einräumen, während er heute sagt, ne, die Merkel hat da so eingeladen und da gab es gar kein Protokoll oder so, sondern es waren dann so private Unterrichtsstunden für Merkel und er hat dann einfach gehofft, dass daraus was kommt. Also der zeigt da so ganz große Enttäuschung. Und wir lesen Nils Seibert, der war fürs Neue Deutschland beim Sozialgericht. Und da wird ja relativ viel öffentlich verhandelt. Da gibt es dann immer so Strafdinger wie 50 Tagessätze, 15 Euro. Also so geringfügiges Zeug, jemand hat einen Shampoo geklaut, ist schwarz gefahren oder wie auch immer. Und er hat sich hundert solcher Fälle einfach vor Ort angeguckt, die nach Mündlichkeitsprinzip verhandelt werden. Und wir denken jetzt, Nico Semsrath hat ein depressives Buch geschrieben. Das ist ein depressiver Text. Also da bleibt wirklich nichts lebensbejahendes übrig, wenn man anschaut, wie mit diesen Leuten da umgegangen wird.
Das ist sehr düster heute also. Naja, wir haben ein Streichquartett, das wird also sehr heiter. Da will ich noch ein paar Anmerkungen generell mal machen. Wir können uns also im Salon gleich sehen oder hören. Ne, man kann uns nur hören, gar nicht sehen. Man kann uns nur hören, also es ist ganz intim. Und zwar ist das möglich, wenn ihr ein Abo über Steady abschließt. Das geht am besten über die Seite neuezwanziger.de. Da ist oben ein goldener Button, dann kommt man auf die Steady-Seite und dann ist eigentlich alles selbsterklärend. Mit wenigen Klicks ist man dann im Salon. Kann diesen Podcast dann auch überall dort hören, wo man auch sonst den regulären Neuezwanziger-Podcast hört. Wer schon bei Apple ist und dort bleiben will und auf keinen Fall noch irgendwo anders was abschließen will, der kann uns auch über Apple abonnieren. Da ist es aber ein bisschen teurer, da Apple immer ein bisschen mehr Geld auch haben möchte von uns dann. Und es gibt noch die Möglichkeit, wer schon da einen Account hat, uns über Patreon zu abonnieren. Und es ist ja ganz erstaunlich, dass wir auch einige Leute haben, die nur den Salon hören.
Das stimmt, mein Spargel zum Beispiel.
Die das melden, die dann sagen, sie hören nur den Salon und hören die reguläre Folge gar nicht. Also ja, diese Möglichkeit gibt es auch. Wir werden also jetzt wieder wichtige Texte des Monats vorstellen. Und dann sehen wir uns im Salon.
So ist es. Und am 24. August, ich habe nachgeschaut, es gibt noch 80 Tickets oder so. Also ungefähr 10%. Wir wissen, dass es natürlich mitten in der Urlaubsaison liegt. Aber ich werde Wolfgang nachher vorschlagen, was wir da im Detail machen.
Okay.
Wir können alle sehr gespannt sein.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, ja.
Gut, bis gleich.